je reçois maintenant michel houellebecq
le phénomène des lettres françaises de
cette fin de siècle l'auteur des
sulfureuses particules élémentaires
dresse le bilan de son succès littéraire
elle nous parle de ses projets d'avenir
bref voici houellebecq à livre ouvert
michel houellebecq bonsoir à vous est
demandé de venir parce que c'est la
dernière émission je dirais comme les
autres après ses cannes donc on voulait
que vous soyez notre dernier invité de
l'année parce que vous avez marqué
l'année voilà alors les particules
élémentaires donc je rappelle chez
flammarion sous la direction littéraire
de raphaël sorin alors évidemment ce cas
disons-le a été le plus étonnant dans le
bouquin c'est cette espèce de haine de
la permissivité hérité de 68 et le le
fait que la fin de l'autorité la fin de
la religion la fin du couple
ça rend les gens dingues et si j'ai bien
compris deviennent des particules
élémentaires un peu des électrons libres
comme ça alors ça ça a effectivement été
choquant parce que c'est vrai et la
deuxième chose qui a aussi choqué les
gens c'est finalement ce que vous disiez
sur le clonage en disant qu'il fallait
dépasser la la dichotomie eugénisme
égale nazisme pour aller plus loin et
vous disiez même que vous étiez plus
choqué par l'avortement que par le
clonage voilà alors j'en arrive
maintenant à ma question ce n'est pas
moi qui parle c'est le personnage avez
vous souvent répétées dont il ya eu
cette ambiguïté qui fait que le roman de
houellebecq est devenue la sphère
houellebecq mais enfin chez moi
tranquillement enfin comment vous avez
vécu ça c'est à dire que vous avez passé
votre temps finalement à répondre sur
des interviews précédente et à vous
justifier de ce que disait vos
personnages en fait le clonage sa joie
une toute petite place dans le roman
c'est à cette heure que j'ai j'ai mis un
prologue et un épilogue qui répondait au
prologue qui sont un peu indépendant du
roman et où on bascule dans la science
fiction en fait par le par le clonage et
l'immortalité et je ne pensais pas que
ça ferait un effet aussi foudroyant que
tout le monde me parle de ça pour moi
c'est une espèce d'hypothèses
un proche quelque chose de littéraires
pour rajouter une espèce d'éclairage
leur manque est en fait tout le monde a
beaucoup insisté je m'en a parlé de ça
parce que c'est vrai que la littérature
s'empare tellement rarement de la
modernité de l'avenir de la science
c'est ce qui se passe en ce moment avec
le bouquin de dantec
vous avez sûrement lu babylon babies
c'est-à-dire qui d'un seul coup les gens
sont surpris et c'est bien parce que la
littérature lui de raconter des petites
intrigues de coucheries à droite à
gauche raconte de la réalité
d'aujourd'hui est bon en fait moi pour
moi c'était de la science fiction mais
je me suis demandé si c'était une si
mauvaise idée le clonage tout compte
fait au fond bon j'étais surpris que au
départ que tout le monde déteste ça un
tel point que l'idée soit si choquant
donc j'y ai repensé depuis je me suis
dit pourquoi pas oui reproduction par
clonage
oui pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ça mais
c'est vrai que ça me choque pas
énormément vous êtes est sans doute le
premier à en parler dans la littérature
de cette brouille survenue en saxe a
fait ce choc-là et puis aussi ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire cette
remise en question de l'héritage de 68
où je caricature certes mais enfin dans
votre roman les serial-killer sont
quelque part les héritiers des hippies
donc c'est vrai que c'est des choses qui
sont difficiles à entendre pour les oui
mais ça fait comme on me l'a aussi je
pensais que ça serait plus calme parce
que je me mettais dit que 68 ça faisait
quand même trente ans donc on pouvait en
parler calmement comme d'un truc
appartenant l'histoire qu'on en fait
problème c'est que les gens sont encore
au pouvoir quand ils ont beaucoup et les
gens qu'il avait 20 ans 68 ils ont 50
ans madre ils ont ils ont bien résisté
alors effectivement il est plein de gens
qui l'ont mal pris oui pour moi c'était
assez lointain enfin c'était moins de la
haine quand guy lancer fluence est un
peu de la préhistoire et pour beaucoup
de gens c'est là c'est leur histoire
donc vous avez comme un journée cela
écrit j'aime bien l'expression vitrifiés
la rentrée je trouve que ce beau et
assez juste
vous en êtes aujourd'hui à 265 mille
exemplaires ce qui est bien vous et
gagner de l'argent et pour ça alors vous
avez un nouveau look maintenant on
faisait le look françois valéry quoi oui
j'ai su me suis aperçu que ça
ressemblait françois valéry oui c'est
vachement bien
c'est étonnant
j'ai peut-être faire des reprises de
france paul van haver on va reparler
après avec votre ami burgalat oui alors
maintenant si vous avez envie de faire
un bouquin pour dire que finalement la
vie est belle quand on a de l'argent et
qu'on habite en irlande
est-ce que sur le plan marketing ça va
poser des problèmes si vous êtes en mer
dès maintenant pour faire un livre en
disant que la vie est belle ou non mais
là bon non mais je bondis c'est vrai
qu'on perd le droit de se plaindre
ouais mais ça même dans la vie privée
j'ai plus le droit de dire je suis
malheureux personne ne veut même pas ce
que c'est visiblement pas vrai et c'est
ça donc je vais faire des trucs plus
plus bizarre ça je vous fais confiance
revienne parce qu'il ya des choses
bizarres aussi mais je veux le faire
publier des poèmes
oui on en parlait justement il
m'apparaît de la rentrée non je jouais à
pour terminer sur les particules
élémentaires et après on passera à
l'avenir
c'est vrai qu'on regarde on va regarder
un petit sujet parce que vous n'avez pas
eu le goncourt donc on en a assez parlé
surtout ici et dans cette émission
françois nourissier un jour nous a dit
que lui entre les camps ce qui le
concerne il aurait bien décerner le
goncourt à michel houellebecq et on va
regarder ça magnéto est alors
houellebecq ça c'est la question que
c'est quand même le roman qui a marqué
la rentrée
oui houellebecq pour moi c'est une
question sérieuse je le défendrai c'est
un secret
de l'avoir éliminé avant la bataille
finale je pense que ce n'était une
erreur je crois que c'est une erreur
il n'aurait sans doute pas trouvé à
l'académie goncourt de majorité pour
avoir le prix mais au moins le haut et y
aurait-il été vaincue dans la dans le
dernier combat dans la dernière bataille
à un contre b&you peu du fort contre et
dupont ouais ça aurait été mieux que
c'était cette élimination tout d'un coup
il est il est tombé il est tombé à l'eau
là on a plus ces jeunes heureux je
regrette je vous ai pas peur que le prix
80 18 soit un peu comparé aux prix
mazeline en 1900 enfin aux primes à zlin
à la ferme adeline en 32 et en toutes
choses égales ou inégale d'ailleurs je
l'aide pour nos amis téléspectateurs que
le cerin n'avait pas été couronnés et
madeline avait été couronnée alors je
pense que pour le consensus n'est pas
madeline on ne sait pas si houellebecq
tu seras céline mais je il n'en reste
pas moins que l'événement jusqu'à
aujourd'hui de la rentrée 98 c'était
l'apparition de houellebecq pour son son
second roman on l'a occulté
je le regrette voilà c'était donc
françois nourissier dans cette émission
le jour où le prix goncourt avait été
décerné à paul constans leur paule
constant michel houellebecq
vous avez dit que vous préfériez encore
que ce soit paul constans colis des
rôles ah oui oui parce que olivier rolin
son côté fo bon livre ouais alors que
bon paule constant mais il est moyen
sans plus quoi vous été assez violent
après cette affaire du prix goncourt
parce que moi je vous ai vu sur une
chaîne se balade c'est idir les jurés
étaient payés ou il me rembourser mon
regretté d'avoir dit çà ou non oh bah
non parce que tout le monde le
le monde le sait oui mais mais j'étais
pas trop
fâché pas c'était un peu du dépit quand
même nous ont posé la question mais moi
je suis peut-être violence en s'en
rendre compte je me rends pas compte moi
j'avais l'impression que c'était une
évidence bowie mais ceci dit toutes les
vérités sont pas toujours bonnes à dire
mais ceci dit c'est assez bourrin
nourricier la ouais enfin c'est quand on
est tous là donner le prix lui quand on
est très vieux en fait il ya un moment
de sincérité qui bouscule tous enfin
c'est ça va c'est bizarre mais c'est pas
très grave
non alors d'abord c'est pas grave je
n'ai pas vendu 260 vous avez exemplaires
aujourd'hui c'est pas fini ensuite j'ai
quand même eu le prix novembre c'est pas
grand chose mais cette joie bien
toujours 200 mille francs dont vous êtes
parti veut partir en irlande c'est pour
les impôts ou pour avoir le total look
écrivain non c'est pas pour le look
écrivains en fait ouais c'est vrai qu'on
paye moins d'impôts on paye que la
cotisation sécu par ailleurs j'ai envie
de prendre à parler anglais mais ça
c'est un peu une autre raison c'est que
vous en fait j'ai plein d'ennemis et
finalement je suis pas très doué en
polémiques et dans le monde anglo saxon
il ya un truc très agréable que c'est
que personne ne connaît et les gens qui
me connaissent sont des amis donc c'est
exact c'est exactement comme à mes
débuts au frein est lent mais aussi
beaucoup d'amis enfin disons d'amis mais
je vous rassure et aussi beaucoup de
gens nient qu'ils considèrent votre
livre comme un livre important à la plus
plus compliqué expliqué bon par exemple
dans dont beaucoup de romans du xixème
siècle
il ya des personnages qui parlent
français avec des romans allemands ou
russes parce que c'était la langue
allant de l'élite la langue de l'élite
maintenant indiscutablement c'est
l'anglais donc j'ai envie de mettre des
passages en anglais je parle pas très
bien anglais puisque comme ça va prendre
oui mais j'apprends je progresse vous il
ya quelqu'un alors je vais vous le dire
ça au passage comme ça qu'on a connue
grâce à vous parce que c'est un ami à
vous c'est nos gaz qui est un type
formidable on l'a invité ici il vient
pas souvent la télé nos voisins on a
invité ici ça s'est très très bien passé
bon je dis ça parce que quand il ya eu
le procès de l'espace du possible
vous avez fait un procès parce que vous
citiez la leur vrai nom et vous disiez
principal c'est des trucs pas enfin que
voulait pas qu'on dise dans tous les cas
alors qu'ils vous avez attaqué et noguez
jeu relevé ça c'est intéressant il dit
on est en pleine marchandisation du
discours on ne pourra plus dire coca
cola c'est de la merde oui ils ont la
pub pour s'exprimer et nous on n'a pas
le droit de dire ma toyota a des ratés
c'est le truc le plus emmerdant qui me
soit arrivée en fait ça risque de si on
a plus si j'ai pu moi comme je cite
constamment beaucoup de choses de la vie
quotidienne y compris des noms de marque
si j'ai plus le droit
elles devraient s'insurger contre cela
va avoir du mal oui je pense que nos gaz
à raison de s'insurger et c'est pour ça
que j'en parle parce qu'il n'est pas
question que le et la pub et que les
autres n'est rien foncée marron de
dominique noguez est l'auteur d'un un
très bon livre au fait qu'à pas vu assez
de succès à l'époque c'était les
derniers jours du monde et qu'un des
premiers romans apocalyptique ont fait
fin de millénaire mais je sais c'est ma
gens qui partent de biarritz il est venu
ici vous a raconté son histoire sur
lénine qui avait rencontré les
surréalistes et lénine dada voilà il est
très étonnant et c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qu'on a eu plaisir à écouter
qui est un peu comme vous qui est
quelqu'un qui n'aime pas trop les médias
qu'un torrent fermé comme ça mais quand
il quand il raconte ses bouquins ont
plus qu'assez génial alors apparaître
vos projets maintenant parce que quand
même bon leur machine ilan et les
particules en continu alors à la rentrée
vous publier un recueil de poèmes c'est
vrai oui oui c'est vrai et
certes pour ce bon je publie un recueil
de poèmes ce genre je vois à peu près ce
que je vais faire un jour n'est pas très
long et puis certains poèmes je vais
essayer de les dire avec de la musique
alors justement les goergl s'est fait un
disque il ya un disque est sorti
produit par bertrand burgalat qui
s'appelle au coeur de tricatel alors
vous faites là dessus vous faites un
morceau voit pour le moment il ya juste
un morceau ces séjours que l'avancé ça
et jour clubs ont été cassées le riff de
la boum avec quelques nappes de violons
en passant aéroports et là vous êtes
parti pour faire un vrai un vrai disque
entier avec avec d'organes à howie une
dizaine de titres une dizaine de titres
oui mais bon je sais pas chanter je
pense que d'aucuns dont le blanc il ya
peut-être quelques titres où ça peut
aller de dire avec de la musique
sinon je pense que plus généralement ça
serait mieux qu' un autre interprète que
moi je pense que je suis bon pour faire
tuer parole mais pour 20 piges pas j'ai
pas du tout le suis pas capable de me
produire sur scène enfin ça m'intimide
trop un jeu c'est quelqu'un de très bien
burgalat témoigne très connu ben il ya
un numéro de technikart
on parle et c'est vrai que dans le coeur
de tricatel il ya valérie lemercier qui
est son ancienne compagne
et puis une reprise de marie dô éric
caire aussi unique kyle qui fait une
reprise de marie lou de polnareff très
très bien alors c'est vrai que j'allais
faire une tournée des plages
c'est un peu exagéré ailleurs on va
ailleurs mais le 2 juillet 2 et 3 puis à
prêcher pas très bien ouais mais pour
faire quoi
oh bah moi j'ai envie de faire au moins
une fois dire des poèmes avec de la
musique ont pu avancer pour ça alors oui
moi je fais ça l'est les autres aussi
d'ailleurs mais les autres ils chantent
dans les municipalités peuvent vous
inviter à avoir emploi voire houellebecq
pour une soirée musicale
oui on peut essayer mais ça donne des
idées aux autres têtes attention alors
oui alors vous allez vraiment dans
l'actuelle parce qu'il ya le film qui
sort votre précédent livre qui
s'appelait extension du domaine de la
lutte donc qui est le film est fait par
philippe harel qui a fait la femme
défendue et isabelle carré qui a touché
les randonneurs donc ça vous avez vu
déjà des choses ou prévu le film à
bray-dunes film n'est pas il est pas
mixer mais il est monté et alors vous
êtes déçu pas déçu non non je
je suis content moi je me suis bon en
fait extension du domaine de la lutte
c'est c'est un livre vachement marrant
par moments il y avait vraiment des
scènes drôles mais quand même le fond
est restée règlement triste et ont été
faits oui moi ça m'a effaré par moments
je me suis dit que c'était courageux de
faire un film aussi hocini les séries
j'ai pris conscience du nihilisme de
votre livre en voyant le film et en plus
c'est même pire que c'est parce que j'ai
participé au scénario ouais mais en
voyant le truc vous est possible je suis
comme ça un carnet oui j'ai eu un moment
de terreur mais c'est vrai que par
moments c'est drôle aussi même faune
variée on vous connaît la vie du cadre
moyen est désespérant un langage aussi
les ailes de le part les cadres qui
d'ordinaire votive alors là vous allez
partir faisait pas alors d'abord est ce
que est ce qu'on va trouver un cinéaste
qui aura le jeu dirait le talent pour
adapter des particules élémentaires est
ce que déjà vous avez été contacté par
des par des cinéastes belges et ouais
mais ça je ne sais pas mais en fait
philippe harel est arrivé au bon moment
c'est à dire que ça faisait déjà trois
ans que j'avais écrit extension est donc
en fait ça me dérangerait pas de refaire
un scénario comme et là je peux là par
contre les particules élémentaires non
j'ai pas trop envie d'y penser
personnellement je veux bien que des
gens le fassent mais j'ai d'accord je ne
vois pas replonger dedans photo pour
reprendre et alors vous allez partir en
voyage là ça peut d'ailleurs inspiré
votre prochain livre parce que vous êtes
traduit vous être traduit dans 20 pays
vous êtes obligés de partir d'aller
faire ça vous embête pas les séances de
signatures comme ça avec les gens qui
vous intéresse à vous comme si vous
connaissez depuis toujours et qui vous
parle
à vrai dire j'en ai encore jamais fait
l'étranger ouais mais bon j'ai fait pas
mal d'interviews déjà et je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y avait plus de
différences entre les deux pays même
proche que je my way essaimant par
exemple les anglais quand il faut une
critique de libre raconte beaucoup plus
l'histoire que
que les français en lisant des critiques
j'avais l'impression presque les
particules élémentaires et est un
thriller la question il disposait
étaient les français considèrent pendant
là lui aussi la halle où il répété en
fait ils donnent leur avis oui c'est
très différent et les allemands c'est
encore autre chose enfin nous et elle en
belgique
oui oui j'ai déjà remarqué qu'en
belgique il ya une plus grande liberté
d'esprit qu'ici sur tout un tas de
sujets les gens sont plus libres sont
moins politiquement correct en france en
d2 par contre en suisse ils sont le pire
ah oui là je vais terminer simplement
sur une phrase je sais pas ce que
j'allais en dire mais moi c'est une
phrase de vous que je trouve formidable
si je me sens parfois très proche de moi
même
est ce que ça vous arrive dans d'autres
arrivent souvent se sentir très proche
de vous même
mais non là j'essaye de de m'écarter
justement pour pour des poèmes parce que
c'est beaucoup plus éclaté comme des
poèmes fait donc je non contraire là je
ne suis pas très proche de moi même
parce que je je mets des choses que je
trouve bien mais eux mais je trouve très
bizarre d avoir écrite moi même donc je
m'écarte un peu de moi même les
particules élémentaires sur la fin ces
personnages là je commence à les trouver
lourd je crois pas que j'aurais fait 600
pages quand j'ai fait des absents mais
je commence à en avoir un peu marre de
moi même des personnages que je me
doutais bien qu'on ne mélangera mais
personne n'a ri c'était c'était le
problème des ans mais en même temps
c'est c'est un compliment quand on vous
mélanger vos personnages c'est que c'est
qu'on y croit on se dit là pas pu
inventer
en tous les cas ce que je peux vous dire
pour conclure c'est qu' il est très rare
qu'un livre marque autant une année
littéraire c'est arrivé c'est même pas
quand est-ce que c'est arrivé pour la
dernière fois à quoi c'est l'année où el
bec
ouais ouais ben on va continuer alors
restez toujours maintenant vous êtes
vraiment très en forme très françois
valéry rester comme ça mais oui mais je
mais c'est le champion et bien je vous
rappeler si vous avez un petit alwett -
blanc vert qu'à l'époque quand même
peroxydée complètement françois
d'essayer de faire un peu ringard pop
merci michel houellebecq et ont
crédibilisé je rappelle le titre du
livre si besoin est ça s'appelle les
particules élémentaires donc et c'est
chez flammarion
les corrections de nourrir un t2
inhabituel abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou